[Music]
this might take a few tries
I'm Barry Allen I'm a fastest man alive
I also think that I am on the wrong
earth I'm gonna need your help
hey everybody if you didn't hear Tom
Welling was teasing a crossover with the
flash so I'll try to explain what he was
talking about what that means and how it
would work plus they also confirmed that
they're doing Legion of super-heroes in
the DC TV universe this year so it's
gonna be crazy but if you're finding me
for the first time be sure to subscribe
to get everything
episodes are getting ready to start so
there'll be a weekly flash ring giveaway
that I'll explain at the end of the
video so the big news first like big
Smallville crossover and everybody's
like how come Tom Welling wasn't the
Superman on Supergirl previously well
he's actually a very private person so
he hasn't done really anything
associated with DC TV since he ended his
Smallville run and of course when
Supergirl came along they went to all
the Smallville actors like they went to
the teri hatcher Dean Cain Superman
characters too and were like do you want
to come on so Dean Cain was like yeah of
course I'll be on the TV show but I
think largely because of what Supergirl
looked like in its first season he's
like that's a totally different tone
totally different show
he said he turned them down this is the
audio clip from that I've been asked to
like show up on some of the shows that
you know you know whether it's the arrow
or the Supergirl and things like that
and that I don't think that's
necessarily for me that's what they
asked me to and I say the same thing
it's not because of disrespect it's like
hey we gave you 10 years I gave you 7 it
was great I you know it's just like
Superman also there's an ego to it it's
like Supergirl is a show with the lead
characters and I don't want to come in
and be like a secondary character that's
not me right now and it's sounds like a
dick I just don't go hey Lex Luthor is
gonna show up for two episodes it just
doesn't make sense it's a different show
totally different it's it's they're what
they're doing is great what we had was
special and I just don't want to mess
that up
you know we did was something that was
something else so mind-blower Michael
Rosenbaum was also probably offered the
role of Lex Luthor in a guest appearance
on Supergirl 2 so this is basically said
that we don't want to come on as like a
gimmick for an episode and then go away
but Tom Welling himself said that he was
not opposed
- doing crossovers so he's on Lucifer
now which is another DC TV show which
isn't really connected to the DC TV
Berlanti verse it's kind of off by
itself in the Fox Universe but the
character he's playing on Lucifer is the
first time he's coming back into the DC
Universe so of course people have been
asking him again what about a crossover
with Smallville so he's like I actually
have an idea for a crossover so his
basic pitch for a Smallville crossover
is just to have the flash Grant Gustin
run through small bill and that would be
the set from the classic Smallville TV
show like he'd be the Kent farm like the
clip that I included so he hasn't
completely said no - absolute crossover
anything like that I think he's just
reticent to actually put on the blue
Superman costume but I think the better
idea would actually be to wait a little
bit longer till he gets a little bit
older and you basically do an older
version of the Justice League from
Kingdom Come and you throw like John
Wesley Shipp in there with an older
version of Wonder Woman you could
basically do the older versions of the
characters you could even wait till
Stephen Amell is old enough to come back
and visit the shows because old shows
will get cycled out like eventually when
arrows done Stephen Amell will go off
unto other things but he can come back
and guest stars the green arrow on the
other shows like Titans is getting ready
to get started so eventually we'll get
to the point where we have characters
from the DC TV universe that are old
enough to play the Kingdom Come older
versions of the Justice League
characters so you could just do that
version of Tom Welling from an alternate
earth it really the best thing I think
about bringing him back into the DC
universe even if it is on Lucifer is
that he's been so private the last
couple of years I think getting him out
of his shell a little bit and getting
him warmed up to the fandom will get him
a little more excited about doing
crossover stuff so we've already got the
Aquaman from Smallville that's going to
be playing a character on Titans we've
already got Erica Durance from
Smallville playing super girls
Kryptonian mother on the Supergirl TV
show so there's just a lot of Smallville
crossover that's already happening it's
just a simple twist of Cisco's powers to
have them accidentally pop up on small
builders and legit connected to the DC
TV universe so I think they're just
waiting for the right opportunity for
that but if you did watch Smallville you
know that they did Legion of
super-heroes
I'm sure we'll be able to reprogram
what's left of Brainiac into something
useful
let's hope Brainiac 5 is a little more
friendly I'm sorry I doubted you kal you
did stop Brainiac and without taking a
life and if you ever want to meet the
rest of the Legion just put this ring on
I've reprogrammed it for time travel
only no flights not yet so looks like
you have to learn to fly without
training wheels just focus on 3009 we'll
be there to greet you thanks I think
I'll stick closer to my time zone for a
while now they've confirmed that they're
doing it on the Supergirl TV show mostly
through the Montel character but they
just cast a character called Saturn girl
who's like a legit core member of the
Legion of super-heroes she'll be coming
to help them out and while they don't
mention it by name they just mentioned
Saturn girl she just comes out of
nowhere she was born on Titan in the
distant future so it's not like she just
pops up out of nowhere because at the
end of last season his pod went into a
portal that looks just like the portals
that Barry enters when he time travels
so the idea is that he's going to come
back during season 3 and he'll have been
to the future and met some of these
Legion characters but they haven't said
exactly how they're gonna tease that out
only that Legion things are happening
they already teased the ring in the
fortress of solitude so the Smallville
on the Supergirl TV show already knows
that the Legion exists but if you're
wondering why characters like when they
know things like that just don't tell
everyone it's just because they're not
ready to do that story yet so it'll be
like ah Saturn girl I know Saturn girl
she gave me my Legion ring that's in the
fortress of solitude so just leave all
your bonus video requests for season 4
flash arrow stuff that's coming up my
episode videos will obviously start
posting it's the second week in October
when everything starts dropping
they changed the channel in Canada so
wherever you live in the world just make
sure you know which channel it's airing
on and remember which day it's coming on
but here's my big recommendation for you
if you live in Europe sometimes I think
it's Skye that airs the episodes they
wait several weeks to start airing them
so I would just recommend that you find
a way to start watching them when people
in North America get episodes because if
you wait you will be a couple weeks
behind and there's so much stuff that's
happening the first half of the season
on all the TV shows so there was a whole
bunch of new stranger things season 2
that dropped today along with Rick and
Morty so I'll try to get through those
videos as fast as possible but just a
reminder that stranger things season 2
is premiering at the end of October and
then obviously there's a whole bunch of
Rick and Morty finale stuff that's
happening
now so we'll say there's a new round of
the flash ring giveaway all you have to
do to enter just be a subscriber leave a
comment on this video
announce a new winner the next time I
post DC which would be later this week
I'll talk a little bit about what's
going on with reverse flash in the
reverse flash that's Barry from that
Earth x4 night crossover that's
happening so while you wait for that
click here for brand new flash footage
and you can click here for brand new
Rick & Morty thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight